donc mon camp d'entraînement encore cet
après-midi en arrivant vers 14 heures
je trouve qu'on a encore volé notre
barrière
en plus ils ont vandalisé le site
rendent ils ont vandalisé le titre la
loi comme étant les tables les chaises
des enfants ils ont tout pris aussi ce
parti avec la ville ont vandalisé au ras
de la poubelle là ils ont ils ont
facturé aussi le cadenas qui étaient là
la moitié des matières qui étaient là
dedans royaume pour le site ya pu y a
plus de petites barrières de sécurité
doubler les gens dans tout le canada
donc je pense que c'est une méchanceté
jalousie de quelques peut-être que j'ai
un poulet avec et qui s'amuse à jouer à
ce jeu là donc il faut que cette
solution comme les plots des petits les
plots des enfants aux français qu'il ya
une partie dans le canal aussi notre
style